an instinct like that might actually have consequences,
because the first thing that I discovered is that it's not just me.
In 2007, the Washington Post reported that the United States military
was testing this robot that defused land mines.
And the way it worked was it was shaped like a stick insect
and it would walk around a minefield on its legs,
and every time it stepped on a mine, one of the legs would blow up,
and it would continue on the other legs to blow up more mines.
And the colonel who was in charge of this testing exercise
ends up calling it off,
because, he says, it's too inhumane
to watch this damaged robot drag itself along the minefield.
Now, what would cause a hardened military officer
and someone like myself
to have this response to robots?
Well, of course, we're primed by science fiction and pop culture
to really want to personify these things,
but it goes a little bit deeper than that.
It turns out that we're biologically hardwired to project intent and life
onto any movement in our physical space that seems autonomous to us.
So people will treat all sorts of robots like they're alive.
These bomb-disposal units get names.
They get medals of honor.
They've had funerals for them with gun salutes.
And research shows that we do this even with very simple household robots,
like the Roomba vacuum cleaner.
(Laughter)
It's just a disc that roams around your floor to clean it,
but just the fact it's moving around on its own
will cause people to name the Roomba
and feel bad for the Roomba when it gets stuck under the couch.
(Laughter)
And we can design robots specifically to evoke this response,
using eyes and faces or movements
that people automatically, subconsciously associate
with states of mind.
And there's an entire body of research called human-robot interaction
that really shows how well this works.
So for example, researchers at Stanford University found out
that it makes people really uncomfortable
when you ask them to touch a robot's private parts.
(Laughter)
So from this, but from many other studies,
we know, we know that people respond to the cues given to them
by these lifelike machines,
even if they know that they're not real.
Now, we're headed towards a world where robots are everywhere.
Robotic technology is moving out from behind factory walls.
It's entering workplaces, households.
And as these machines that can sense and make autonomous decisions and learn
enter into these shared spaces,
I think that maybe the best analogy we have for this
is our relationship with animals.
Thousands of years ago, we started to domesticate animals,
and we trained them for work and weaponry and companionship.
And throughout history, we've treated some animals like tools or like products,
and other animals, we've treated with kindness
and we've given a place in society as our companions.
I think it's plausible we might start to integrate robots in similar ways.
And sure, animals are alive.
Robots are not.
And I can tell you, from working with roboticists,
that we're pretty far away from developing robots that can feel anything.
But we feel for them,
and that matters,
because if we're trying to integrate robots into these shared spaces,
we need to understand that people will treat them differently than other devices,
and that in some cases,
for example, the case of a soldier who becomes emotionally attached
to the robot that they work with,
that can be anything from inefficient to dangerous.
But in other cases, it can actually be useful
to foster this emotional connection to robots.
We're already seeing some great use cases,
for example, robots working with autistic children
to engage them in ways that we haven't seen previously,
or robots working with teachers to engage kids in learning with new results.
And it's not just for kids.
Early studies show that robots can help doctors and patients
in health care settings.
This is the PARO baby seal robot.
It's used in nursing homes and with dementia patients.
It's been around for a while.
And I remember, years ago, being at a party
and telling someone about this robot,
and her response was,
"Oh my gosh.
That's horrible.
I can't believe we're giving people robots instead of human care."
And this is a really common response,
and I think it's absolutely correct,
because that would be terrible.
But in this case, it's not what this robot replaces.
What this robot replaces is animal therapy
in contexts where we can't use real animals
but we can use robots,
because people will consistently treat them more like an animal than a device.
Acknowledging this emotional connection to robots
can also help us anticipate challenges
as these devices move into more intimate areas of people's lives.
For example, is it OK if your child's teddy bear robot
records private conversations?
Is it OK if your sex robot has compelling in-app purchases?
(Laughter)
Because robots plus capitalism
equals questions around consumer protection and privacy.
And those aren't the only reasons
that our behavior around these machines could matter.
A few years after that first initial experience I had
with this baby dinosaur robot,
I did a workshop with my friend Hannes Gassert.
And we took five of these baby dinosaur robots
and we gave them to five teams of people.
And we had them name them
and play with them and interact with them for about an hour.
And then we unveiled a hammer and a hatchet
and we told them to torture and kill the robots.
(Laughter)
And this turned out to be a little more dramatic
than we expected it to be,
because none of the participants would even so much as strike
these baby dinosaur robots,
so we had to improvise a little, and at some point, we said,
"OK, you can save your team's robot if you destroy another team's robot."
(Laughter)
And even that didn't work. They couldn't do it.
So finally, we said,
"We're going to destroy all of the robots
unless someone takes a hatchet to one of them."
And this guy stood up, and he took the hatchet,
and the whole room winced as he brought the hatchet down
on the robot's neck,
and there was this half-joking, half-serious moment of silence in the room
for this fallen robot.
(Laughter)
So that was a really interesting experience.
Now, it wasn't a controlled study, obviously,
but it did lead to some later research that I did at MIT
with Palash Nandy and Cynthia Breazeal,
where we had people come into the lab and smash these HEXBUGs
that move around in a really lifelike way, like insects.
So instead of choosing something cute that people are drawn to,
we chose something more basic,
and what we found was that high-empathy people
would hesitate more to hit the HEXBUGS.
Now this is just a little study,
but it's part of a larger body of research
that is starting to indicate that there may be a connection
between people's tendencies for empathy
and their behavior around robots.
But my question for the coming era of human-robot interaction
is not: "Do we empathize with robots?"
It's: "Can robots change people's empathy?"
Is there reason to, for example,
prevent your child from kicking a robotic dog,
not just out of respect for property,
but because the child might be more likely to kick a real dog?
And again, it's not just kids.
This is the violent video games question, but it's on a completely new level
because of this visceral physicality that we respond more intensely to
than to images on a screen.
When we behave violently towards robots,
specifically robots that are designed to mimic life,
is that a healthy outlet for violent behavior
or is that training our cruelty muscles?
We don't know ...
But the answer to this question has the potential to impact human behavior,
it has the potential to impact social norms,
it has the potential to inspire rules around what we can and can't do
with certain robots,
similar to our animal cruelty laws.
Because even if robots can't feel,
our behavior towards them might matter for us.
And regardless of whether we end up changing our rules,
robots might be able to help us come to a new understanding of ourselves.
Most of what I've learned over the past 10 years
has not been about technology at all.
It's been about human psychology
and empathy and how we relate to others.
Because when a child is kind to a Roomba,
when a soldier tries to save a robot on the battlefield,
or when a group of people refuses to harm a robotic baby dinosaur,
those robots aren't just motors and gears and algorithms.
They're reflections of our own humanity.
Thank you.
(Applause)